i have placed information vital to the
survival of the rebellion into the
memory systems of this r2 unit
my father will know how to retrieve it
this is the nebula capsule 2
star wars r2d2 projector with this
limited edition model it features the
r2d2 design
and for the startup sound it even
includes the voice of r2 which is pretty
damn cool
this mini projector has android tv 9
installed so you can enjoy over
5 000 apps including youtube disney plus
twitch netflix and more this means you
can watch thousands of movies like
revenge of the sith
or even your favorite content creators
on youtube
there are several other uses for this
device if you wanted to you could use it
as an
extra monitor for your pc for gaming or
what i also like to use it for a
bluetooth speaker
i gotta say the sound quality really
blew me away it sounded a lot better
than i was expecting
and this was nicely complemented with
the hd picture
overall i'm really happy with the
product and i definitely think people
will be satisfied with it so the links
to their website
and products will be in the description
so please make sure you go check that
out thanks for watching